[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous vous AZ fait quoi
Tex pas de Burger ce
soir alors on va commencer par un tout
petit jeu bon un petit sondage vous
aurez juste à lever les mains si vous
êes dans le cas qui parmi vous un
compteien réseau social Facebook
Instagram et tout ça main
ok merci pour ceux qui pas lever les
mains je doute un peu de votre
sincérité mais c'est bon pour
l'esprit du sondage alors à V on voit
que près de 95 % de la
salle en un ou plusieurs compes liés à
des réseaux sociaux c'est pour vous
montrer l'importance du digital dans la
notre vie de tous les jours
o l'importance l'influence digital sur
sur chacun chacune de nos
entreprises je suis euh Goris salin
trésor proire d' restaurant Texas Grill
euh je commencé en 2015 pas en 2016
comme elle a dit mais en 2015 sur une
table avec deux employés aujourd'hui je
suis à quatre restaurants avec près de
employés qui avec qui je travaille tous
les jours je récupère des gens qui sont
presque sans formation par parce que je
me dis que j'ai pas eu de formation en
cuisine moi j'ai fait l'informatique et
et l'économie donc j'ai appris sur l't c
une inspiration et aujourd'hui je forme
plusieurs personnes euh dans mes
resta3ant près de 200 personnes pour qui
je suis une inspiration ou bien une
influence donc j'ai vraiment pas pas
voulu impacter plus de monde que ça mais
j'arrive si aujourd'hui je suis avec
vous à tdex c'est pour dire que je
quelque part nous abattons un travail un
peu sérieux quand même merci alors ce
soir je vais vous parler de l'influence
à l'air du digital j'aurais voulu vous
raconter ma vie mais je vais vous parler
de l'influence à du digital euh mais
attendant je vais commencer par une
petite histoire alors en 2010 de retour
de ses études en Inde un jeune ivoirien
était à la recherche du meilleur
hamburger
d'Abidjan
malheureusement il il n'ava pas trouvé
un qui était capable de ramener à ses
souvenirs d'étudiant
et quelques années plus tard il décida
d'en faire un lui-même il en fit à la
maison il pris le pain le remplit il le
partagea à sa
famille il le partagea à sa famille
alors tout le monde était
subjigué toute ma famille subjigué par
la qualité du burger et surtout le
goût ce soirl j'ai pas dormi si vous
êtes deviné je parle bien de moi j'ai
pas dormi j'étais tellement fier de ce
que j'avais accompli malgré tout ce que
j'avais fait comme travail
mais pour un seul burger les les les
mots que que j'ai eu euh m'ont vraiment
touché le lendemain matin je suis allé
faire des achats j'ai fait deux burgers
j'ai fait goûter même cette fois-ci aux
voisins ils étaient tous contents
c'était les mêmes remarques les mêmes
mots CIT un déclique pour moi parce que
c'est la première fois que je faisais
quelque chose qui avait de la valeur aux
yeux des
gens je je venais de découvrir ma
passion ma passion qui était vraiment la
cuisine
la
restauration alors tous les jours je ne
faisais que faire des des Américains des
hot dog des burgers je vouis juste faire
goûter goûter aux
Géta pas la recherche de l'argent je vis
de découvrir ma passion je voulais la
partager pour la partager je me suis dit
bon si je le PO sur sur mon mon compte
facebook je va plus plus toucher de
monde et dire aux gens que je fais le
meilleururger du monde alors j'aié sur
ma page mais j'ai pas eu l'impact que je
recherchais me dit bon peut-être que
comme c'est un compte personnel je vais
faire une page je fais une page qui
s'appelait d'abord Houston grill j'avais
jamais eu une idée de faire un
restaurant et je partageais mais j'avais
toujours pas l'impact que je recherchais
de fil à aiguille je me suis retrouvé un
jour sur une
table devant une boîte de nuit une
petite table comme les femmes qui vendre
des oranges la ché j'ai commencé à faire
des
burgers j'avais pas laffuence parce que
je me disais que mes gars du quartier
Les Tontons les tantill allaient venir
il ne venaient pas les gens me voient de
loin mais dévis ils
vont parce que voir des burgers des des
des cottes de por sur un grillage dehors
c'était un peu bizarre pour eux et
surtout qu'on avait pas de restaurant on
était juste dans la poussière même et
une terrasse cétait au nous donc c'était
il ne venait pas du
tout alors je décide de changer le nom
de de Houston grill que c'était ça en
Texas Grill je mets Texas
Grill léger impact pourquoi parce que je
me dis Texas c'est le coin par
excellence du barbecue grills c'est
parce qu'en Afrique nous avons des
grillades que des grillad et moi ma
spécialité c'est de faire des grillades
à la sauce barbecue que j'ai
créé je commence à avoir un impact je
commence à voir plus de personnes
légèrement de plus de sones j'ai dit bon
peut que jeis en sponsorisant ça me
ramener encore plus de clients parce que
de les 10000 les 20000 que j'avais
chaque jour ne me suffisait vraiment pas
je décide de sponsoriser à 100 à 1
dollar par jour en semaine et 2 dollars
en
weekend en weekend
euh je me suis rendu compte que j'ai
commencé à perdre de l'argent CIT ça
devenit un cauchemar donc au lieu de
gagner de l'argent sponsorisant j'ai
commencéis à perdre de l'argent c'està
chaque jour je sponsorisis je commenais
à perdre de l'argent mais pourquoi parce
que je faisais une erreur de ciblage je
ne ciblais pas du tout je sais pas ce
qu'on appelait le ciblage je me suis dit
qu'il suffisait de mettre de l'argent et
ça l'a amené des clients mais pendant
que maive quiit les enfants de Cocodi
était de en train en train de
dormir les gens de corogo de boakeé de
yamsoko c'est qui qui laent le yamsocro
or quand il en like ça diminue euh ton
budget donc avant que les gens de cocod
se réveiller les gens de kogoà fin de
liker et j'avais pas les clients j'avais
les likes c'est sûr mais les clients n'y
étaient
pas alors pour moi la première leçon la
première leçon à at tirer c'est que tout
le monde peut ouvrir tout le monde peut
avoir un compte tout le monde peut
ouvrir une page mais tout le monde peut
pas le gérer une page il faut avoir il
faut faire des sacrifices il faut avoir
euh de l'information pour pouvoir gérer
sa page donc il faut vraiment s'informer
et se former d'abord pour pouvoir gérer
sa page en deux je conseille aussi à
tous ceux qui veulent qui rentrent dans
l'entrepreneuriat de créer eux-mêmes
leur page et de la gérer au début au
début pas pas à la fin mais au début de
la gérer pourquoi pour éviter ce qu'on
voit de nos jours c'est-à-dire on a volé
ma page on m'a éjecté de mon groupe que
j'ai créé on m'a fait ceci on m'a fait
cela il faut le faire
soi-même pourquoi parce que nous sommes
des entrepreneurs pour la plupart
quand tu commences à entreprendre c'est
là que tu as le plus de temps au monde
ça moi je l'ai remarqué pas remarqué
mais je l'ai remarqué pourquoi parce que
tu en même temps que tu es tu es le DG
tu es le producteur tu es le comptable
mais pourquoi est-ce que tu pe pass le
temps aussi pour être le CM de ta page
pourquoi est-ce que tu ne parles pas de
ce que tu
fais au monde toi tu veux juste compter
de l'argent au lieu de parler de T
produit que tu fais donc je pense que
c'est très important de commencer à être
le CM de sa page de de parler ensuite
quand on va arriver peut-être à 30000
pages à 30000 abonnés à 50000 abonnés on
peut déléguer mais en délégant on aura
mis son esprit dans sa page et une fois
que le CM fait quelque chose d'autre on
pour dire NON ne fait pas comme ça mais
faile comment moi je je me gè avec mes
abonnés ça corrige une erreur que d'un
notre jour en Côte d'Ivoire tout le
monde est
cm le cm en même temps qu'il va gérer
une plage de placaliie il va gérer une
plage de livraison il va G
une page de vente d'habit et tout ça et
il a la même manière de travailler sur
toutes ces pages alors que c'est pas le
même
esprit chapeau à ivoirien qui ont des
pôles qui forment des groupes qui on où
chacun a son pôle c'est que moi je gère
et la gastronomie l'autre gère et les
habits et
tout la deuxè
leçon la deè leçon que je voulais
partager c'est que il faudrait garder
son son authenticité quand j'ai commencé
moi j'avais pas image j'avais pas de de
photographe j'avais pas de de personnes
pour pour créer mes contenus alors je
partais prendre des des des contenus des
burgers sur des pages américaines des
plats sur des pages américaines que je
venais poster sur ma page mais pour le
faire il faut s'assurer que ce que tu as
posté là tu peux le reproduire parce que
c'est un couteau à double trenchant tu
peux aller prendre des habits des choses
que tu vas prendre et que tu viens
poster le jour que le client vient tu ne
peux pas le reproduire tu p crédibilité
et tu perds tes
clients tu perds tes
clients tout à l'heure il y a mon frère
qui est passé en premier qui disait euh
il faut
atteindre il faut faire la discipline
c'est le fait de répéter de de refaire à
plusieurs fois
oui parce qu'on atint jamais un état
d'excellence ça c'est ma 4e leçon c'est
on natteint jamais un état
d'excellence il faut toujours le faire
répéter ce qu'on fait répéter ce qu'on
fait pour sortir le meilleur de
nous-mêmes
et Dieu apporte l'opportunité c'est pas
l'argent qu'on recherche on recherche à
maîtriser ce qu'on fait quand Dieu
apporte l'opportunité il faudrait que
vous soyez prêts alors que quand
l'opportunité arrive on n'est pas prêt
moi avant de devenir j'ai reçu un soir
un un Européen à ma terrasse quand
j'étais encore sur le feu et
euh quand il est arrivé il a commandé un
burger moi je l'avais pas
remarqué le lendemain on a était
submergé c'est la première fois que je
vois des clients donc de de de 20000 de
10000 on est passé àprès de 300000
francs de recette en fin de soirée je
vais demander à un client mais pourquoi
est-ce que beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui
comme ça il dit mais il y a un Européen
qui a fait un retour sur vous et qui a
dit que partout il est passé au monde
dans tous les pays qu'il a fait il n'a
jamais mangé un un aussi excellent
burger que ce qu'il a mangé hier soir à
Texas crille alors nous sommes venus
pour voir c'est quoi qu'est-ce que tu
fais com comment tu
prépares ce soirl j'ai vu beaucoup de
voitures venir g il y a d'autres qui
pouvaient s'asseoir il y a d'autes qui
disaient mais c'est si que Thas grill là
ça c'est ça queas grille il ne pouvait
pas s'asseoir la vision m'est venu en
même temps en tête me dire que mec pour
recevoir autant de monde pour recevoir
une certaine qualité de personnes aussi
il te faut des
restaurants et la vision est née à
partir de là que je devais ouvrir des
restaurants si je voulais jamais
recevoir des gens d'une certaine d'une
certaine qualité si jeis augmenter mes
prix moi j'ai commencé à par de 1000
francs les mêm plats aujourd'hui je suis
à 10000 Fran à 15 les mê plat je n
jamais triché dans tout ce que je
faisais ma vision arrivé et je devais
ouvrir des restaurant donc il faut être
prêt pour que quand Dieu apporte
l'opportunité vous soyez prêt il faut
toujours être en train de s'entraîner
toujours en train d'être d'essayer de
faire quelque chose de mieux que ce
qu'on a fait la veille
maintenant je vais vous poser une
question comment vous
sentirez-vous si
jamais l'œuvre de votre main l'œuvre de
votre vie quelque chose pour lequel vous
êtes B vous avez bataillé vous êtes
battu vous avez suyer sang et sueur on
venait vous dire qu'on on allait le
casser le lendemain comment est-ce que
vous
sentiriez-vous alors le 5 mars le 5 mars
je reçois un appel dans la soirée de la
mairie qui me dit
écoute on vient on sort d'une réunion
avec le
gouvernement ils vont casser ton
restaurant que tu il y a 2 mois dans 48
he il mais comment c'est pourquoi parce
que tu fais de
l'embouteillage quel genre
d'emboutillage j'ai j'ai un parking de
20 voitures et il y a le goud mais moi
je ne g pas le Goudo mais j'ai un
parking de 20 voitures mais comment
est-ce qu'on va C comment c'est possible
on ne sait pas mais si tu as quelqu'un
que tu connais
quelqu'un qui peut influencer merci pour
le thème d'ailleurs quelqu'un qui peut
influencer la
décision là tu peux parce que dans 48 he
on casse ton restaurant moi je
connaissais personne je venais de
d'arriver de de l'IND quand je suis
parti en Inde j'ai perdu ma mère mon
père d'abord et ma mère l'année qui a
suivi j'ai perdu mes deux parents donc
j'avais plus personne qui pouvit me
protéger qui pouvit parler pour moi je
savais pas qui
VO le lendemain je vais la propriire du
terrain min la constion par
48 pour voir si on pouvait essayer de G
du temps et tout ça pour
discuter
onsieur Mach son chez toi c'est pas
demainourd't che toi il v rentrer
CER le temps de dire ce que vous PZ sor
les Ch on cassé tout
lesis
Mo cuisin qu'ona fait venir dont tout
démoli je me rappelle je sais que
c'était un mercredi parce que mercredi
c'est jour de euh comment appelle ça les
trucs de la présidence là réunion
ministérielle bien Conseil des ministres
voilà et donc à 13h ils ont cassé
j'étais très triste à 13h je pense que
après à la fin du Conseil des ministres
d'abord quand j'ai quand on m'a annoncé
j'ai fait un poste la veille qui
expliquait Mor RAL bol ma frustration et
tout ça la veille et en quelques heures
ça a été partagé partout dans le monde
je pense que ça a été partagé aux
États-Unis en France en Côte d'Ivoire ça
a été relayé j'étais tellement étonné
euh de cet impact je sa pas qu'on me
connaissait autant et ça était parti
j'ai eu près de près de 2000 à 3000 part
cè fois je faisais un poste qui qui
partait à 3000
partages le lendemain Conseil de
ministres après le conseil de ministrre
qu on fin de démolir mon restaurant je
pense que mon téléphone commence à
crépiter ça appelle de partout chaque
directeur de cabinet de ministres
m'appelle les secrétaires de ministres
m'appellent on veut te voir le ministre
veut te rencontrer en un jour j'ai dû
rencontrer près de près de presque tout
le gouvernement en un jour et même le
Premier
ministre pourquoi parce que l'influence
que cette affaire a eu sur le sur le net
a tellement chamboulé que il il s'est
arrivé à eux chacun amenait son
chauffeur venu me chercher viens on va
te recevoir ne parle plus ne dis plus
rien on va te dédommager pourquoi ne
parle plus c'est la force des réseaux
sociaux c'est la force digitale donc
avec le digital vous voyez l'influence
qu'on peut avoir moi qui
Nava restmol j'ai pas de voiture j'ai
rien on m'appelle on mène ici viter
ministre minist ministre ça ça été une
leçon pour moi pour dire que les réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux c'est un
outil vraiment
puissant dans notre vie de tous les
jours et surtout pour nous qui sommes
entrepreneurs ça redirige presque tout
le seul poste que le monsieur a fait
averti à manipuler l'envie des gens moi
qui reço que peuttre 10 clients par reçu
200 personnes en une journée donc ça
manipule l'envie des gens ça manipule
leur désir ce qu'il on envie de faire ça
peut les changer en une minute voici la
force des réseaux sociaux tu es ass ta
feminit une image n tu
es connais parce que la nu tuas aller
chercher ce qu'elle a vu pour envoyer
donc ça c'est très fort l'outil l'usage
l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux en moins d'un mois après j'éis
je pense j'étais à 13000 abonnés quand
ils ont cassé mon restaurant en moins
d'un mois je suis passé à 60000 près de
60000 abonnés en moins d'un mois
aujourd'hui je suis à 200000 abonnés et
plus et donc c'est et ces abonnés là
au-delà d'êt des abonnés représent une
communauté pour moi une
communauté grâce à qui j'ai
pu 2019 à la même année ouvrir un
nouveau restaurant parce que le capital
smpathti j'en ai profité capital
sympathique quand tout le monde venait
me dire Yako glisser une enveloppe faire
ceci j'ai PUV j'étais prêt en même temps
à ouvrir un nouveau restaurant j'ai
ouvert un restaurant euh cette
communauté a permis que je puisse être
prier meilleur jeune entrepreneur parce
que quand on a cassé le restaurant
j'étais sur une terrasse avec tous tous
ces entrepreneurs qui avaient des des
bureaux des trucs bien lotis moi de ma
terrasse de mon petit fouau j'ai été
primier meilleur entrepreneur de l'année
j'ai reçu une prime de 100 millions j'ai
été primier meilleur entrepreneur par
par vodou euh le prix saon de 2019 c'est
moi qui l' remporté encore j'ai j'ai
remporté le Prix meilleur PM
restauration et tout ça c'est grâce au
digital et grâce au capit sympathie que
j'ai eu
donc pour vous dire qu'en un mot nos
abonnés ne sont pas souvent des abonnés
on peut avoir beaucoup d'abonnés et ne
pas avoir d'impact clair vous pvez avoir
des abonnés je vois des gens qui ont des
pages de de 1 million de followers et
qui ne peuvent pas avoir un impact ces
abonnés quand ils font des postes ne
suivent pas donc il faudrait au-delà
d'avoir des abonnés il faut les
transformer il faut les transformer en
en en je sais pas comment quel mot je
j'ai perdu mon mot il faut les
transformer en en communauté il faut
qu'il Devi une communauté qui vous suive
dans tout ce que vous
faites vous savez les avantages les
avantages de ce buzz a permis que moi de
ma position où j'étais en 2010 Facebook
m'a
appelé ils m'ont donné une
formation sur 3 mois on m'appelait de
l'esp Espagne j'ai eu une formatrice de
Facebook directement pendant 3 mois qu'
m'a formé euh à l'usage du
digital et cela a été très bénéfique
pour moi parce que le résultat
aujourd'hui d' recette euh de combien je
peux pas dire les mots sont passés à à
ça
de de un restaurant je suis passé à à
plusieurs restaurants aujourd'hui euh là
nous sommes en train de signer un
contrat avec
euh la compagnie aura je sais pas c'est
comment appelle de de la compagnie de
pétrole ola ola nous reprenons plusieurs
stations ola c'est en cette fin d'année
et en plus de Dakar où ça nous serons
aussi avec
ola j'ai été grâce aux réseaux sociaux
j'ai été mis comme le celui qui gère le
président de la section restauration
pour l'accueil de de toute la canne vous
voyez alors ça c'est l'importance
vraiment du digital parce que on te
recherche on te prime l'année passée en
novembre en décembre euh j'ai été dans
la délégation du Premier ministre pour
le sommet aux États-Unis c'est la
première fois que je partais aux
États-Unis tout le monde me voit tout le
monde pense que j'is j'ai déjà été aux
États-Unis non c'est la première fois
que je partais en décembre passé la
première fois que j'ai quitté le
vraiment le continent véritablement je
suis allé aux États-Unis au sommet USA
Afrique avec le président
américain je suis reparti avec
l'ambassade des États-Unis qui m'a fait
partir en juillet euh se met des des
franchises l'année passée c'est pas le
résultat de ton travail c'est pas ton
l'argent que tu comptes mais c'est
l'impact que tu as ce n pas que ta
communauté a sur le digital quand
quelqu'un veut recevoir son son visa
bien son passeport d' maazone il dit
envoyeer ça à Texas gu l'ambassade amène
ça directement à Texas gu vient le
récupérer ça c'est c'est vraiment un
impact que nous avons sur le digital
merci beaucoup moi je voulais partager
mon
expérience merci
beaucoup mettez les cœur